[Music]
so this is uh yesterday with danny
baldwin curtis phil
well pick up a camera and get with your
friends
to start off with because some people
have
genuinely done that you know
picked up a camera
shot something got into sundance and
you know been making feature films a few
years later and now it really
has never been this easy to do something
so there is the opportunity
as you as you get a sense of film and tv
production to move up move across move
along i'd like to thank richard and sue
for sort of coming along today this is
the games industry as a whole all the
different jobs all different roles
everything within it
yeah i mean i know guys have still been
you know the board of directors have
been doing it for like 40 longer than i
have um
yeah absolutely i mean i wouldn't it's
for me it's just one of the best
industries i wouldn't have been doing it
for 30 years if it wasn't
we have linked up with the curiosity
event
to give students an insight into finance
careers in finance and west summit
college particularly in the courses and
offer of finance and business that we
offer to students i've got an auntie
that works in banking and
it's just a career path that seems
interesting so i thought i'd come along
see what's about
i came along because um i've i've always
not really i've had
some ideas on what i want my future job
to be i haven't really had any concrete
ideas so i thought i'd explore something
new which i'll soon be pretty successful
throughout the years so i thought this
would be a good one to try out
basically i had a week it seemed
interesting and potentially looking at a
career in something financially i found
out i think it was through
through school so school emails or on a
facebook page i think
you really need to be
abreast about what's happening in the
world so you need to be uh have
bbc app on your phone follow the news so
you actually know what's happening
because that will directly filter
through to prices
and my mindset is that rather than
asking someone if i can do something i
just got on and did it so
i thought i could put on a gig so i put
on a gig
so yeah i mean if you're creative
um instagram is brilliant pinterest you
know all the channels that i don't use
tik tok so videographers are doing
amazing work on on social media as well
so these days pr campaigns a good pr
campaign should include
some really exciting content online we
have such a broad range someone can
create stuff at home that sounds you
know just as good to most of us as it
does there so the power is a bit more in
our hands the way our funding works is
it is
is all about you and your development
and how good the opportunity is for you
so it's very difficult to talk broadly
about what you should and shouldn't do
because it's that our assessment process
is tailored to you i think there's
nothing better in terms of having long
real success than people coming to see
you and hear your music and liking it
and then coming back again that's kind
of it's really it's great because it's
really tangible isn't it
[Music]
you